voilà donc ce premier acte s'est joué il
ya clairement une heure et quart je vous
invite à regarder donc ce qu'était
l'énoncé des résultats du scrutin par
philippe seguin député rpr
abolitionnistes et vice président de
l'assemblée nationale
c'était le plan de séance d'aujourd'hui
le premier qui je rappelle et est ainsi
libellé la peine de mort est abolie
nombre de votants 487 suffrages exprimés
480,2 majorité absolue deux cent
quarante deux pour 369 contre 116
l'assemblée nationale a adopté
42 membres de l'opposition ont ajouté
leurs voix à celles des socialistes et
des communistes
parmi eux jacques chirac rpr et michel
d'ornano udf monsieur bart a voté contre
côté socialiste un sel votre style et
une abstention le garde des sceaux avait
dû ferrailler une bonne partie de
l'après midi pour obtenir court qu'un
additif ne soit apportée à cette
décision
il avait promis à ceux qui dans les deux
camps souhaitait obtenir des assurances
pour que les criminels ne soient pas
remis
trop rapidement en liberté ed avril le
parlement serait saisie des textes sur
l'exécution des peines et le plus vite
possible au plus tôt dans un an
hull et celle de ses peines serait
révisée un certain nombre de députés rpr
et l'udf ont refusé leur suffrage lors
du vote sur l'ensemble des six articles
motif le texte gouvernemental ne prenait
pas en compte leurs préoccupations
ils n'ont été qu'une dizaine et maître
badinter dit sa satisfaction
dire c'est une majorité qui a dépassé
jamais l'horizon
c'est important significatif que sur
l'essentiel c'est à dire l'article 1er
on ait eu une majorité si large s'il a
pas de 25% de l'opposition actuelle
réunis autour de l'abolition c'est un
normalement dans son histoire ici